I am a ghost Annelise soldier
[Music]
trained to strike my enemies before they
know I exist
death stalks me but I survive
overcoming any obstacle
[Music]
never surrendering
you
[Music]
Anthony Perriman was an army brat who's
born in Boston and has been a known to
us as nomads at the age of 18 he
enlisted in the army earned a bachelor's
degree and later became an officer by
his mid-twenties nomad was recruited by
the elite Special Operations force of
the United States Army also known as
Delta Force after several missions with
Task Force 88 he joined the ghosts and
rose through the ranks to become a team
leader during a difficult mission in
Eastern Europe in 2017 Nomad became a
ghost lead after a mission went wrong in
Ukraine and his team leader was injured
his first full mission and his
leadership role was a hostage rescue
operation in the Amazon jungle at the
border between Brazil Venezuela and
Colombia this was also the first mission
for the newly formed team of ghosts
composed of Nomad Weaver halt and midis
two years later the team was sent to
Bolivia as an undercover force to stop
the Santa Blanca cartel from turning
Bolivia into a narco-state after the
completion of the mission in 2019 in
several other operations Nomad is now
looking to retire and has accepted one
last mission on a remote Pacific island
nomads always remains completely calm
even when placed under considerable
pressure here's the epitome of the
strong and silent soldier stereotype
able to hold back any kind of emotions
and able to remain completely objective
in any circumstances past teammates
would joke about checking his pulse
during freefall jumps to make sure he
was still alive he OS kids ANSI went on
rest and recuperation and has trouble
adjusting to the mundane day-to-day life
were not deployed of course this has an
effect on his personal relationships
outside of the military he has been
married and divorced twice with a
teenage son from his first wife he
struggles to maintain a good
relationship with her son who blames
them for never having been around when
he was growing up no man is looking to
retire to make up the lost time with the
son who's about to become a father
himself he dislikes the fact that he has
to keep his true occupation in the
military a secret from his family
especially his son but respects and
halted secrecy without falter in the
beginning when he first became a ghost
leader he often had a hard time finding
the right balance between being a
mission-driven leader and a member of
the team now on his last mission he has
no problem putting personal aspects
aside and executing the objective has
been assigned with at times Nomad is
something of an introvert and is
considered not really the talkative type
by others like most spec ops units goes
to lists for more than conventional
units as are the relationships between
officers and the men and because of the
secret nature of their work the members
of the ghost team almost always only
exclusively socialize with each other
prior to operation Kingslayer nomads
unit was caught up in the Mexican
rebellion after being recruited into the
ghosts he was assigned to a squad with
halt Midas and Weaver during a mission
in Donetsk pölten Midas were injured and
nomad was put in charge of the new squad
which highly displeased him due to a not
being ghost Protocol their mission was
to retrieve and or destroy a downed UAV
in South America and rescue some
archaeologists and a research team from
the local militants who keeping them
hostage it was around this time that
nomad witnessed surveillance footage of
el Sueno executing the family of a
Bolivian police officer even today he
states this footage still haunts him and
he vowed to do everything within his
power to stop the cartel leader july
2019 the US Embassy at Lopez was bombed
by the Santa Blanca drug cartel leaving
two marine guards injured and a DEA
agent kidnapped the motive was to
capture the undercover agent was later
confirmed by the ghosts to have been
tortured and killed but elsewhere knew
no meds team was covertly deployed into
Bolivia with a medic with Bowman it was
while in Bolivia that he first
collaborated with Col Dee Walker they
became friends and the two later worked
very closely
the Santa Blanca cartel has turned
Bolivia into a knocko state and have
crippled the government the Bolivian
government formed an anti narco
operations unit called you need ed to
counter the rising cartel but the
fighting was ending with more unit ed
casualties than cartel forcing the
president of Bolivia to make peace with
the Santa Blanca the team continues to
dismantle the cartel systematically
eventually attracting the attention of
El sueño himself the drug reaches up to
the ghosts and arranges a meeting though
he has no way to be found when the team
arrives he offers the ghosts positions
within his organization but the refused
the ghost continued to take down the
leadership of the cartel before
eventually meeting up with El sueño
himself and arresting him
[Music]
nomads team would be called back into
Bolivia by Karen Berman to extract a
skel tech engineer who's been arrested
by unidad he is knowledge of sensitive
American industrial secrets and must be
protected nomad unexpectedly comes
across major Col Dee Walker a fellow
ghost team leader who was there with his
own agenda he found out that the
engineer was the one who designed the
skeltox drones for uni dead after you
need had modified and weaponized them
the head two of Walker's teammates
killed Walker doesn't just blame the
engineer but also Berman for allowing it
to happen after extracting the engineer
to a safe house nomads intercepted a
call from Bowman - thus celtic engineer
walker had placed a tracker on the
engineer and he and nomad found out that
he sold out bowman to the uni dead so
that he can get passports to leave
bolivia walker and nomad catch up to the
engineer and walker execute them they
then find bowman tied up and extracted
to a nearby rally point during the
argument between bowman and walker nomad
convinces walker to see reason knowing
that he trusts nomad walk Alex Bowman
live but warns that he'll be coming to
collect on the debt if she steps out of
place again while glad it didn't turn
Missy no Matt understands that the lost
Walker has been through and doesn't
blame him for his anger
in February 20 22 no Madden Walker
along with several ghosts were deployed
in the Middle East running
counterterrorism operations late on the
deployment Walker committed her morally
questionable and illegal act he executed
an officer who'd put them all in danger
this officer was also the son of a u.s.
senator
no man refused to testify against him
and in turn will collect the ghosts in
2025 Aurora the new home base of scale
technology was mysteriously cut off from
the world after a u.s. cargo ship
mysteriously sunk near the archipelago
with allegations towards the company the
US government decides to send in the
ghosts CIA deputy director Peter miles
Zintan nomad now promoted to lieutenant
colonel and a leader of 32 ghosts his
team along with three other teams the
mission is to investigate the island and
if possible extract J scalp Nomad and
his team along with the other teams
aboard the USS Wasp were flown to the
island but on their way are taken out by
a drone swarm
Nomad halt the silly fix-it and fury are
the sole survivors the rest of his team
are either killed or in my a he and the
surviving ghosts are hunted down by
former ghosts and no meds ex
brother-in-arms Walker
along with other ghosts who have gone
rogue with them known as the wolves
Nomad and the ghosts find shelter at
erawan which is home to the homesteaders
Nomad manages to find another ghost
Josiah Hill after that no man finds Jeff
skel shortly after he is attacked by
Walker and Hill who was defected to walk
aside
Nomad manages to escape along with Skell
skelion formulates a plan to take down
the drone control program along the way
Nomad and the ghosts help out key
employees of Skell tech eliminate
Sentinel commanders and walkers
lieutenants later on Nomad manages to
track down Walker and has him killed
he then deactivates the during control
program by uploading scales virus taking
down the drones protecting the island
and stopping Walker's plan of taking out
the world leaders which involves using a
lethal killer drones which were to be
deployed by the missiles launched from a
submarine
[Music]
Nomad is an expert at making tough
decisions and unleashing the full
potential of a squad he is a weapons
specialist and uses skills and
psychological warfare to beat his
enemies at their own game he is an elite
world-class soldier but as with all
soldiers that comes a time when they
choose to hang up the gloves no man's
motivation his family but before going
down that path in retiring he decides to
run one last mission however what he
didn't know was that this will be his
most difficult operation yet with the
majority of the 32 ghosts under his
command having died before they even set
foot on the island he has some
unfinished business to sort before he
can take on his next charge the
readjusting into civilian life
there is a huge amount of story in this
addition to the franchise and I've
really started to dig down into it but
before I can discuss any of that stuff I
really need to make sure I'm covering
the basics before I go I was chicken
through some of my settings on YouTube
the other day hoping that I'd find
something that maybe screwed up there
could be the reason why I keep getting
demonetized and has stumbled across the
membership section I had no idea how
many of you joined the five-dollar paid
subscription thingy it seems strange or
and get notified you know I thank you
very much to all of you you certainly
helped me out a lot through a rough time
where the majority of the time it seemed
to be completely blocked off from
earning from the revenue and Christmas
which makes it pretty de motivating and
difficult to justify the amount of time
I put into these videos if you have any
ideas of what I could be providing and
snip section please let me know
otherwise thank you very much for
watching and I'll catch you in the next
one
Cheers
[Music]